hey everyone this is Steve wine shop
with collider and I am thrilled to be
talking to the two of you about
dollyland yeah
um I really want to start with
congratulations on the movie
um uh I know I hate saying this but so
many people watching this will have not
seen the movie yet so how have you been
telling your friends and family about
the film how do you want to tell the
audience
um I mean a lot of it like how I tell my
family because they're excited for me I
start with uh I say James the character
I play is a um
is a kid thrown into a world a lot there
we go yeah I'm not used to holding
microphones
um he's just he's a kid who's curious
and thrown into a world that he has no
idea
um
what we'll do with him what it will do
with him what the world he's entering
will do to him
um and that's sort of the the Curiosity
that he uh deals with and then from
there it's more so about
and the last years of this legendary
marriage between Salvador Dali and his
wife Gala
um played by the amazing sir Ben
Kingsley and the legendary German
actress Barbara sakova who really go Toe
to Toe on this one oh no they're
fantastic together
um I'm I'm curious because you hadn't
really done anything before Dolly land
and so I'm curious what was it what was
your motivation in casting because you
were essentially I'm not to you know
like an unknown
well yeah he just graduated
um uh I had cast someone else who who I
had to drop out a week into
pre-production so I had to find a James
I had to find the young lead for the
movie and I thought I'm I'm gonna find
somebody new I'm going to go and look at
all the websites all the Showcases of
all the drama schools
and I did and I looked at like at 60 and
I I started at a and I got down to p and
I hadn't found anyone not even a short
list and then I saw Chris's photo and
said oh my God he looks like James
there's no way he's going to be any good
you know that would just be too lucky
right and um and then I I watched some
of the other thought
oh it's good and then so I asked my
casting director just just track him
down and get him to read any of this is
so urgent and he came in right you know
a couple days later
and my husband and I my husband wrote
the script and we just watched it was
like that is James
we just couldn't believe it that we were
so lucky and it's it worked out
fantastic mutually lucky I have to know
what it's like for you the first day
you're going to go to set to work with
sir Ben this is a legend a I mean
literally a a genius actor and you're
literally just starting and you're going
to set the next day the what the f are
you doing the night before how much are
you in your head over thinking things
I'm not sleeping I'm spending most of
the night in the fetal position and
um the only reason I get to set is
because somebody else drives me and
tells me where to leave uh it's it was
terrifying for sure it was terrifying
um but
uh there's also the part of me that
knows that this is what I want to be
doing with my life and is so grateful
for the opportunity and is is in love
with film and in love with acting and in
love with
um their work so you know and there's no
way to get out of it at that point you
wouldn't want to but it was terrifying I
will say I was worried about Chris at
the same time I thought all this fear
that is all this like pressure he's
under in a way he can use that because
the whole part is about a young man
who's you know from Idaho who's thrust
into this sophisticated and quite
dangerous you know emotionally dangerous
New York world and and he can use
this discovery suddenly you're with you
know sir Ben Kingsley in a scene you
know and just use it that was sort of
the only opportunity the only option
just yeah just use it like you did so um
on every shoot there's always going to
be a day that you are really like you
Circle it on the calendar because you
know it's going to be really tough and
you had a short shoot like a five-week
shoot so for each of you what was the
day during the shoot that you had
circled like really nervous about it or
really excited about it
that's a great question uh do you have
something that comes to mind immediately
[Music]
the party scenes were a nightmare
because it was covered and it made it
you know a low budget film you can't
afford a lot of background people covid
makes it even harder you know because uh
it's uh everybody has to be tested
constantly so we ended up with like 40
extras for what is supposedly a big
party scene so when I watch those scenes
and I think they work but I can see that
I we've used the same people kind of
crossing and Crossing you know to fill
the frame so trying to do a big party
with in a big space with that few people
I think the reason you pulled it off
because it works for me and I know what
what you were thinking but because the
room is not so large that's the secret
because I bought that this was totally
legit I bought this was a party so if
you had been in a huge Ballroom it would
have been a disaster yeah yeah totally
and also there are these big pillars so
you could kind of you know I totally
work around it oh good so that was that
what about you
it was all pretty equally terrifying I
mean it really the whole thing was scary
um and I you know I look back and it's
one of the most incredible moments of my
life so far but
um that dinner that dinner when we were
that's what I was gonna say that was one
of the worst moments of my life uh
because there's the scene where they're
all having dinner and it's sort of
James's first dinner at
um in this world and and his boss takes
him to this dinner and Dolly's there and
all these interesting beautiful scary
people are there and
um I mean this was my fault I think I
was a little hungover because we just
wrapped uh Zach the night before and I
had a little too much fun but I I was
panicking the entire day I thought it
was gonna die it was hot it was like 110
degrees it was really high yeah because
yeah we couldn't have any AC we're all
stuck in this little room and it's hot
lights and we're boiling and it's
shooting around table is what a friend
of mine calls the rectangular rectangle
of death yeah you know it's you're
trying to do coverage endlessly and it
was hell that that day was hell yeah I
think that so many people don't realize
what it's really like on a movie set
everyone thinks it's so glamorous and
it's so not it has its moments sure but
it's a lot of waiting right yeah it's 14
hour days and and it's and also to me
it's just like having a sword over my
head from the moment I get on set to the
uh time I leave because of time you know
on on a little budget movie it's very
interesting
um and this was very very and it's cheap
uh is that
you know nothing can be wasted and the
one good thing is that you do have to
actually move very fast and it it
focuses everyone's attention you know so
nothing can be wasted everything has to
move and and some ways in a way good
things can also come out of that I mean
I think you'll find when you as I'm sure
you will do bigger budget things you
know
some it's great to have time to retake
and reshoot but some of that Dynamic is
lost I feel like there was something
really beautiful about the moments you
knew had to work yeah like when it was
the end of the day and you know your
first ID is like we have to go oh oh my
by the way there was something that was
incredible which was
um it was the first week we were filming
in this really big old Bank actually and
it was we redone as a hospital for the
hospital scenes from the very end of the
movie and the lights blue yeah the
entire lights blew in the building so we
couldn't have any lights
and so you know we lost like two hours
and then okay there are no lights and so
in a way it was beautiful we had to
shoot natural light which I prefer and
then
um the beautiful scene between Chris and
Sir Ben when he's giving him the book
back and then and then just this amazing
performance that sir Ben gave when at
the very end and when the cameras I
don't want to give away the end of the
movie but you know as you know you've
seen it when the and I just let the
camera I just I'm just I'm not going to
call cut yeah I'm just going to let it
keep going and going because I think
there's going to be a tear in his eye
I'm just gonna so for a really crazy
long time I let the camera go
keep moving in for both of you what are
you most excited for audiences to see in
the film
I I think I mean just on a if
audience level I think the performances
are so
[ __ ] good yeah all of them I mean
two amazing veteran actors like
legendary actors you know sir Ben and
Barbara but also Chris is amazing
um
Andrea
oh Rupert Rupert's so good oh I'm
telling you I really enjoyed this movie
and but I I love learning about the
behind the scenes of artist lives and
I'm I anyway you know but I but I think
I think to me to me it's like Feast of
acting right yeah yeah and and people
will meet Christmas to watch yeah
um I I have to rap with you guys only
because and I apologize because we have
so many films but I um uh thank you so
much for coming in and um really
congratulations on being part of the
Toronto Film Festival with dollyland and
also one last thing I think the title is
absolutely perfect and I rarely say that
because it is like a land like
Disneyland except it's dollyland yes and
everything that's going around with him
it's a perfect title oh thank you
because that's what that's what we were
thinking it's like you're on a ride you
go on a ride and and and you're in this
world and then all of a sudden you're
out of there you know it's like what was
that
and his life was like inside of a paint
yeah no but um anyway listen thank you
so much thank you I wish you guys
nothing but the best thank you so much